[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight
relief is finally here after tense
negotiations and multiple rounds of
televised theatrics the congress
has passed a definitive spending bill
it's 5593 pages long it amounts to 2.3
trillion dollars that includes nearly a
trillion in covid relief all of it comes
right from the u.s
treasury which is busy printing it right
now that's a lot of money
on the other hand there's a lot of need
thanks in part to government lockdowns
more than a hundred million americans
are out of the workforce tonight
one in six restaurants is closed huge
parts of the retail sector are in
tatters j.crew is in bankruptcy so is
pier 1
neiman marcus brooks brothers century 21
many others so if there was ever a time
that americans need relief
it's right now so be glad to know there
is something for you
in this bill it is entirely possible
that you could get a 600
check courtesy of the us congress
that money should you receive it is
yours to keep
do what you wish buy a moderately sized
television set and watch the free
channels
all night if you want run a tesla for a
day and drive it till the power runs out
or splurge and order two full appetizers
right off the tasting menu with the
french laundry in napa
tip not included whatever the sky's the
limit here
go crazy 600
all for you it's good to be an american
on the other hand it's also pretty good
to be a jordanian this same bill
passed but not read by the united states
congress allocates 500 million dollars
for border security in jordan
that's enough cash to buy the french
laundry in napa a couple times over
but that's not what the money's for
congress wants to help jordan build a
wall
along its 275 mile long border with
syria
apparently congress is worried about
illegal immigration over there and you
can see
why illegal immigration is illegal
and that's bad and that's why congress
allocated another
quarter billion dollars for additional
border security
in lebanon egypt tunisia and oman god
knows those countries need it
borders make a nation remember that
except here
in the united states which is unique
among nations through history
borders are not relevant in fact borders
are racist
and that's why this very same bill which
does so much for the jordanians and the
egyptians the lebanese and the tunisians
and the people of oman defunds american
border security
and ladies and gentlemen we need that
defunding that way we won't be bigots
so the bill slashes funding for ice
detention space and blocks a request to
hire more deportation officials
excuse me it catches in the throat
immigration authorities in this country
will have i beg your pardon
11 000 fewer detention beds
starting this year and if that hurts
imagine all of those people moving here
permanently
they'll have to problem solved it's not
like they're trying to sneak into jordan
vermont senator patrick leahy is excited
about this he bragged about it in a
press release today
there's also you should know 33 million
dollars in the bill for what are called
democracy programs in venezuela because
we're experts on democracy
we're spending 231 million to help pay
down the national debt of sudan and of
course that's another
area of expertise for us national debt
meanwhile
the bill and you want to know this for
certain spends
huge amounts of money to diversify the
workforce in our so-called intelligence
community that's another key
national security objective and just in
case you were worried that american
society wasn't
yet divided enough this bill creates
two new monuments to the interest groups
that have the most political power at
the moment
so henceforth the smithsonian will make
create a women's history museum
as well as what's called the national
museum of the american latino
and that's just here in america there's
a whole lot more for the rest of the
world
this bill spends 10 million on what it
calls gender programs in pakistan now
congress doesn't specify exactly what
those are
lindsey graham seems to know and he's
thrilled about it watch graham's
enthusiasm
this morning pakistan is a place i
really worry about
85 countries a woman can't open up a
bank account without her husband's
signature
she can't inherit property if you're a
young girl in pakistan
life is pretty tough so we're trying to
make life better for women throughout
the world
so lindsey graham is worried about a lot
of things but he's
really worried about pakistan he's not
worried about the fact that pakistan has
built a vast nuclear
arsenal that happened during the clinton
administration graham was in congress at
the time actually
now that's merely a minor concern given
that pakistan is an unstable country
locked in a permanent state of war with
india
lindsey graham can handle details like
that most statesmen can
what concerns him most what he's quote
really worried about is the state of
gender roles in pakistan
now graham who's never had a family now
imagines he's an expert on how the
people of a country
7 000 miles away whose language he does
not speak whose culture he does not
understand
should be running their families lindsey
graham doesn't like how young people in
robel pindy or lahore
too easily accept the customs of their
elders he'd like to shake things up in
pakistani society
he's got big ideas for how to create
more enlightened urdu speaking
households on the subcontinent and he's
going to use your money to do it
we're trying to make life better for
women throughout the world graham
announces
like of course he's capable of doing
that it's now on the list
take out the trash feed the cat pick up
spaghetti sauce
make life better for women throughout
the world it's all in a day's work for
an american politician
overreach you say these are the same
people who can't get the votes counted
in a congressional election
yeah but they've got bigger aspirations
than that and those aspirations are all
over
this spending bill on one page you will
find tens of millions of dollars set
aside to recruit and retain women
in the afghan army okay but
why is the u.s paying for this is that
something that will help
the united states in some measurable way
would help afghanistan
why are we doing this well the real
reason congress is spending that money
of course is because craig's audio logs
in various interest groups and the
federal bureaucracy
would like to change one of the world's
last remaining traditional societies
someday some unhappy 26 year old
american first foreign service officer
can write her master's thesis and gender
studies
on how she undermined the patriarchy in
southwest asia that's the whole point of
it
meanwhile no one in the state department
or the congress has paused to think
about what the afghans think the very
same people who lecture you about
cultural imperialism think it's totally
irrelevant
what the native population might think
of this and in fact it's possible they
may not consider
this progress maybe they are happy with
their ancient
culture unsavory as we may find it
that culture existed a thousand years
before ours arrived maybe they'd like to
keep it
come to think of it why would anyone in
pakistan ever take advice from us on how
to organize a society
you must allow market forces to destroy
your gender role says a civilization
that's become miserable by doing the
exact same thing
yeah no thanks maybe they'll tell us to
keep our money
but no matter what they say we will not
stop sending them
our money foreign aid is the most
effective possible way for the academic
left to export its poisonous social
program to the rest of the world
the roman empire built roads we demand
poorer countries become woke
before long our aid budget will consist
entirely of advanced weapons systems for
the middle east
and taxpayer-funded gender reassignment
surgeries for africa
and the state department will be happy
about that lindsey graham will celebrate
it
but how will you feel about it well who
cares how you feel about it
you got 600 bucks so shut up